if you haven't heard overnight Equifax
released some information that the worst
data breach in the history of data
breaches occurred it's not the largest
but it's the worst and here's what has
happened if you didn't know
Equifax got hacked over the summer they
released that information today a
hundred and forty three million people's
credit bureau reports were invaded in
hacked and the reason it's the worst is
yahoo had a bigger one I had more people
but it wasn't as thorough these people
got your social security number your
date of birth your name your address
they got all the stuff they need to hack
the crud out of you and we're the other
thing they got like a yahoo was like
they got an email address or something
okay but they got everything from
Equifax they cleaned Equifax is plow and
it's bad it is I'm not a hyper guy I'm
not a melodramatic guy but this is bad
and this is the third time recently that
Equifax has been hammered and they're
doing all the correct PR things and you
know requite their CEO there's a
wonderful email man that's if you
haven't seen it you should go look at it
on their website you those of you rick
smith i'm sorry is the guy's name of the
CEO and chairman of Equifax it is a
study in how to handle the public
relations aspect of a disaster like this
the guy is stellar he does everything
he's supposed to do in this situation
doesn't fix the fact that because of
them a bunch of you are screwed and and
this is the third time recently so even
though they did a great job with the PR
handling of it let me give you another
piece of information there are several
class-action lawsuits are already
popping up on this and equifax of course
is offering free monitoring and
free credit repair brought to you by the
people who got hacked so I mean it's a
nice offer but that's kind of stupid all
right and here's the worst part of it if
you sign up for the free monitoring you
in the fine print will waive your right
to sue them little underhanded to stick
that in the fine print that you can't
participate in the class-action lawsuit
because they're the ones that screwed
you I mean they didn't do it
intentionally but this is the largest
debt you know this is the largest
largest database of all of our stuff
that they took from us without our
permission I didn't turn over anything
dekma facts they scarfed it and built a
file on me they did on you too they
collect data on you that's how they
create your credit score you didn't send
them any of that isn't a voluntary
process and it's certainly not a
government agency and and so you know
those of you that worship at the FICO
score here's the price you pay oh and by
the way a bunch of people are tweeting
going Dave Ramsey listeners people who
don't borrow money you know don't have a
credit score I'm really glad I don't
have a credit score it's no big deal
they're not gonna get hit yeah they are
my wife's got hit she was one of them
that's an account that has a zero credit
score and has been frozen for probably a
decade so even if your credit was frozen
and even if you have no credit score
they still got all your stuff my
personal assistants got here so there's
the deal now that's all the bad news bad
news is Equifax sucks Wow
that's not really news okay and they're
gonna screw you again if you sign up for
their free monitoring because you're not
gonna get beat you know you're not gonna
be able to be included in any
class-action lawsuits which I'm not
gonna do personally anyway but I just
think that's slimy you stand in front of
the camera and go we're so very sorry
we're so sorry
we've worked and hard and been diligent
and done everything we wanted to do and
but we're sorry but yeah when you sign
this on the fine print you give up your
right to do a class I can just wrong
just tells you what's really going on in
places like that so I mean
they collect your data against your will
use it for their profit and then don't
protect it that's pretty bad so what do
you do if you're one of the hundred and
forty three million what'll we do with
Sharon Ramsey you know what do we do
well Shan Ramsay has Xander insurance
identity theft protection which means
that if the thieves were to use her data
there's no indication yet that it has
been used just that it's been stolen if
they were to use her data to open an
account and it shows up and fry a
fraudulent account a medical account a
fraudulent social security account a
fraudulent tax account a fraudulent dad
account they open up debt open up a
credit card insuring Ramsey's name that
will be humorous when it because for
divorce if she did it but if they do it
is but if they were to do that then
xander identity theft protection which
you can buy today by the way and I would
suggest you do that because they don't
have any fine print that says you can't
class-action
Equifax is but and their stuff right
there an independent operation and the
difference is not just monitoring you
don't want to just get somebody that
monitors your credit bureau report or
monitors you for identity theft you want
someone who has a caseworker that takes
over all the work and handles cleaning
up the mess if someone utilizes this
theft of identity in order to in order
to open accounts the problem is not that
you owe money the problem is you have to
go through all this hassle and paying
the but working with the credit card
company that you didn't do anything with
and that you don't know any money to but
you're trying to explain to them there's
some scum burger out of a hundred and
forty three million people which by the
way there's 300 million people in the
u.s. a whole bunch of them are infants
and children and a bunch of people are
off the grid completely that absolutely
have no data whatsoever and so out of
300 million one hundred and forty three
million is like everybody that's I mean
it's it's percentage of the data that
they it's like they got all of it just
about I mean you think about that that's
unbelievable and how they not have any
kind of sob
security alarms that go off before
something gets this far in and beyond me
I mean I understand it can happen it
could happen to us
anybody can get hit and by the way your
data is gone it gets stolen by somebody
just kind of super aggravating when it's
those people and so you need identity
theft protection everyone does I've got
it on me I got on my whole family I'd
buy from a whole team so go to Xandar
insurance.com and get that we'll talk
more about this
okay back on the worst data breach in
history the largest theft of importance
detailed information on you 143 million
of you Equifax got cleaned out and again
their CEO and chairman Rick Smith that a
fabulous job on the PR but there's a lot
of stuff that's not right here
one being that if you sign up for the
free monitoring that they're offering
you are down in the fine print being
required to give up your right to be
involved in a class-action lawsuit which
I wouldn't have you to do that anyway so
the second thing that has come out is
three this from Bloomberg three Equifax
senior executives sold shares stock sold
their own stock worth one point eight
million dollars in the days after the
company discovered a security breach
that may have compromised information on
a hundred and forty three million US
consumers the trio had not yet been
informed of the incident the company
said late Thursday the credit report was
a sold stock after it was discovered but
supposedly these guys didn't know it
before it was public because you know
what their stocks doing today right I
mean it's tanking and so credit
reporting service said earlier in a
statement that had discovered the
intrusion on July 29th and regulatory
filings show that on August 1st chief
financial officer John gamble sold
shares worth nine hundred and forty six
thousand three and seventy four dollars
and Joseph Lungren president of us
information solutions exercised options
to dispose of five hundred eighty four
thousand now let me help you with this
the chief financial officer the CFO of
the organization and the guy in charge
of us information solutions didn't know
that there had been a data breach
[Laughter]
really really your chief at your CFO
doesn't know he should be fired just for
being incompetent if your CFO doesn't
know you've had a data breach your CFO's
an idiot I mean you guys are awful
so yeah he knew I'm sorry I don't
believe you
I mean if it was you know junior third
baseman second 15th the guy on the bench
guy he might not have known but the
freakin CFO of a publicly traded company
has a hundred and forty three million
data bridge he knows instantaneously
he's one of the first that's informed he
probably knew before the Chairman's
board knew and if he didn't it just
shows how incompetent you people are so
in either case you're a but you're a
joke you're just a joke unbelievable now
how does this affect you this is all
this important other than me thrashing
Equifax which I just love doing but you
guys know how bad I hate the FICO score
anyway right I mean you know how I hate
you being forced in our culture to
worship at the altar of the great FICO
and you spend all your money trying to
run your score up by borrowing money so
that you can borrow more money and all
this crap that these people have looped
you into and then on top of that they
you know she's unbelievable so I mean
hey everybody can have a data breach I
mean Ramsey solutions could be having a
data breach as I speak and I wouldn't
know it until the other day but I
wouldn't know it but they would call me
at 2:00 a.m. and wake me up okay my guys
would not and we're just a little bitty
unsophisticated company compared to this
one so anyway what do you do if you're
one of the hundred forty three million
the first thing you do is you freeze
your credit bureau account and if you
haven't you need to freeze it it's gonna
cost you a little money but that helps
because anyone who let's say something
let's say the thieves took your name and
applied for a visa card at Bank of
America now Bank of America issues about
eight out of ten visas without checking
credit
so they're going to issue the card
unless you're one of the two out of ten
if you're one of the two out of ten they
check your credit and it's frozen the
card would be denied the thief would not
get to use your identity so a frozen
account does help it doesn't guarantee
but it does help so that's step one step
two is you monitor it you pull copies of
your credit bureau report all three of
them not just Equifax --is you pull them
once a year you should be looking at
them once a year anyway just because I'm
not saying you're trying to run up your
credit score I'm not saying you care
about your credit I'm not saying that
but you just thought to check in on your
electronic reputation and make sure that
somebody's not screwing around with your
stuff right so you need to you monitor
it that's just a smart thing to do
that's just good financial planning to
start with okay you monitor it you
freeze it you have to unfreeze it to
check it and then freeze it back cost
you 20 bucks or whatever just do it okay
shut up
don't try don't wait on Equifax to fix
your problem because obviously they
don't have your best interests at heart
Oh Lord and then you need to get
something like Xander insurance as
identity theft now you guys think I've
turned this into an ad but there's a
reason that I carry identity theft
insurance it's because people freaking
steal identity all the time from
everybody I mean you got target you got
t.j.maxx you got the government
you got Yahoo and now you got Equifax
for the third time has been violated and
they get your information they're gonna
get your information somewhere if you
haven't had a debit card or you those of
you who still use a credit card shut
down due to fraudulent transactions and
the algorithm pops up you're pretty
unusual my debit card was shut down six
weeks ago somebody picked up the number
somewhere started charging stuff at
places that they've never attends and so
we went yeah probably not me at that one
yeah can you imagine yeah so yeah the
algorithm caught that and I wasn't in
Mexico go figure who knew and so you
know shut it down so you're gonna get
your identity theft stolen you need
something like identity theft protection
now remember if your identity gets
stolen
your problem is not that you owe the
money if someone takes my wife's name
which was one of the hundred and forty
three million they got stolen and opens
an account in her name I don't know any
money sharing don't know any money you
don't owe money when someone steals your
stuff okay but you have to convince the
idiots that open the account in my
example earlier the idiot would be Bank
of America right they issued a credit
card without checking credit which makes
them an idiot okay but we already knew
they were idiots it's freaking Bank of
America okay so you you know they didn't
check so now there's a credit card
opened in Sharon Ramsey's name floating
around out there
because somebody stole her information
from Equifax and open a Bank of America
Visa Card this is an example it hasn't
happened okay it's not gonna happen but
then the problem is I can call Bank of
America and get their fraud-victim
division on the line and the first thing
you have to do spend the first 45
minutes of my life convincing these
idiots that we didn't actually open the
account and then we just didn't want to
pay it so we're claiming fraud the first
thing they do is accuse you at the fare
of victim division of the credit card
company of being the thief and you have
to explain them look at doofus we're not
paying this you don't have her signature
on file you don't have her handwriting
on file we're not legally obligated well
you have to file a police report yeah I
will be filing that police report well
you're gonna have to sign affidavits yep
I'll be signing those affidavits but
guess what if you have something like
xander insurances I did any that
protection the real the good identity
theft protection they don't just do
monitoring they don't just do freezing
they take over the problem and there's a
caseworker that cause Bank of America
for us and Sharon and I won't have to
deal with it
and they take care of all this crap and
then it's the hundred hours per account
that it takes to clean this crap up
that's the problem it's not that you
actually owe money it's that it's a
drain on your productivity and now the
very marrow of your bones and that's
what you need to do so freeze your
account monitor your account yourself
and make sure you've got identity theft
protection and it's not too late to have
ID theft protection because again the
reason this is so serious the reason I'm
taking two entire segments on this is
the misbehavior by Equifax in their
handling of this the sale of insider
trading of stock number one
and number two the fine print in the
agreement you sign that we believe you
have the ability to participate the
class-action lawsuit
pretty underhanded and I'll guarantee
you that's not pointed out to you when
it's sent to you stuff you get only on
the Dave Ramsey show but yeah but the
things you can do are what's important
so you monitor it you freeze your
account you get identity theft
protection because no one has you as
stolen your identity yet they just stole
your information it might not ever
actually get used prey that's what up
right now uh I hope it never gets used
out there's never a problem for any of
you but that's kind of unlikely cuz some
Russian mobster somewhere now has your
numbers this is the tape Ramsey show hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]